man sieht die hygienemaßnahmen werden
eigentlich von den wenigsten eingehalten
die stimmung könnte jederzeit hoch
kochen wie ist die polizei da
aufgestellt
also die stimmung ist in der tat rund um
den berliner reichstag sehr aufgeheizt
du sagst es
ich würde sagen 50 prozent der protest
menschen hier der protestierenden tragen
masken die andere hälfte nicht und die
abstände werden hier wirklich überhaupt
nicht eingehalten von cast kann aber
trotzdem nicht die rede sein die
stimmung kocht sich langsam hoch aber es
sind wahnsinnig viele einsatzkräfte der
polizei vor ort neben mir steht frau
dicke sie ist die leiterin der
polizeipressestelle aus berlin
wie ist die lage be hat die polizei die
lage heute hier im griff er wir sind
hier heute mit gut 2000 einsatzkräften
für diese komplexe versammlungs lage im
dienst wir werden dankenswerterweise
unterstützt von einsatzkräften aus neun
weiteren bundesländern und auch der
bundespolizei die komplexität der
versammlungs lage durch dies nicht
nutzen des befriedeten bereich ist eine
besondere brisanz es ist dennoch möglich
gewesen hier eine anmeldung vor dem
brandenburger tor zu genehmigen
die versammlung findet aktuell stark wir
haben mehrere tausend teilnehmenden die
sich zwischen dem brandenburger tor und
der siegessäule befinden
die mindestabstände werden von den
versammlungsteilnehmern nicht einheiten
ein großer teil trägt leider keinen im
mund nasen schutz obwohl das hygiene
konzept das vorsieht wir sprechen die
teilnehmenden an mund nasenschutz zu
tragen
aktuell ist es so dass der
versammlungsleiter der verantwortliche
noch einmal aufgefordert wird einfluss
auf seine versammlung zu nehmen die
teilnehmenden aufzufordern mund
nasenschutz hin zu tragen die abstände
einzuhalten den raum zu nutzen
sollte es ihm nicht möglich zu sein
einfluss zu nehmen oder sollte er es
nicht tun wird die versammlung aufgelöst
werden dann würden wir eine versammlung
auflösung kundtun über unsere
lautsprecher fahrzeuge für jeden
wahrnehmbar auch in mehreren fällen
da haben wir gesehen hässliche bilder wo
es demonstranten gelungen ist die treppe
des reichstags zu erklimmen
und da fahnen zu schwenken da waren dann
drei beamte von ihnen zumindest für uns
zu sehen
wie ist die lage heute haben sie den
eindruck dass die berliner polizei mit
den unterstützenden kräften aus dem
bodens gebiet die lage besser unter
kontrolle hat die örtlichkeit der
angemeldeten und hier gerade
durchgeführten versammlung ist natürlich
eine ganz andere als direkt vor dem
reichstag die zeit der einsatzkräfte und
auch das einsatzkonzept wird die
gleichen bilder nicht noch einmal
möglich machen
im laufe des tages wird sich die
versammlung wahrscheinlich richtung
bundesrat versammeln was denken sie was
der tag heute noch bringt er hat der
erste knackpunkt wird jetzt sein dass
die versammlungsteilnehmer hier hinter
uns am brandenburger tor
die auflagen einheiten dem
verantwortlichen und seinen weisungen
folge leisten
sollte diese versammlung aufgelöst
werden werden die versammlungsteilnehmer
sich sicherlich in andere bereiche
begeben und dann werden wir neu prüfen
werden wir schauen aber auch da sieht
das einsatzkonzept auf umfänglich vor
dass angemeldete versammlung von uns
gewährleistet werden unter einhaltung
der vorkehrungen die nunmal aktuell
jeder zu treffen hat wird zur frage wir
haben festnahmen gesehen warum ging es
da warum sind die leute dann mitgenommen
worden
es hat bislang stadt jetzt eine
deutliche anzahl an freiheits
beschränkenden maßnahmen gegeben
die ursachen hierfür sind ganz
unterschiedlich es geht von dem nicht
tragen des mund nasenschutz gegenseitige
rangeleien also körperverletzung oder
aber auch widerstandshandlungen
gegenüber einsatzkräften eine aktuelle
zahl der straftaten und
ordnungswidrigkeiten die im
versammlungsgesetz eingeleitet werden
mussten werden wir erst in einer
abschließenden bilanz kundtun was
passiert wenn die leute nicht nach hause
gehen wenn die versammlung aufgelöst
werden sollte es seiner versammlungs
auflösungs verfügung kommen wird die
mehrfach über unsere lautsprecherwagen
kund getan so dass jeder frei
entscheiden kann ob er dieser
aufforderung den platz zu verlassen
folgt oder nicht sollten die
versammlungs teilnehmenden der
aufforderung nicht folgen
der einsatz von wasserwerfern an dieser
stelle nicht ausgeschlossen werden da
sind gewaltsame aussichten hoffen wir
dass es nicht dazu kommt hoffen wir dass
die leute hier rund um den berliner
reichstag vernünftig bleiben abstände
einhalten masken tragen und ihren
protest friedlich kundtun
denn das dürfen sie das ist ihr gutes
recht und wir bleiben natürlich weiter
hier vor ort und werden gucken wie sich
der tag und der abend eventuell
entwickelt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren